you may not know it but we're all part
of a massive machine if you look closely
you can see it almost everywhere it's on
the radio and on TV it even affects the
way we conduct our elections and run our
governments but it's starting to break
down and as it falls apart the American
economy could collapse with it to
understand how the machine works let's
take a look at one of the gears meet
Sally the schoolteacher by all accounts
Sally is a great teacher
she works hard every day helping kids
being productive and generating the
income she lives on like the rest of us
the portion of Sally's income is
automatically deducted to pay her taxes
but in Sally's case something else is
taken out - Sally works for the
government and to get that job she is
required by law to join a union unions
work by collecting dues from their
members and then using that money to
lobby for better pay better benefits
better job security in a public sector
union like Sally's the government acts
as a kind of collection agency
automatically deducting those dues from
her paycheck and sending them to the
Union now meet Jim the head of Sally's
Union Jim's got a lot of power
Jim's power comes from the flow of money
that the government sends his Union
every month it's in Jim's best interest
to increase that from
in fact as job depends on it growing the
union is exactly what Jim gets paid to
do so he uses some of the money the
government sends him to pay for a media
campaign promoting his plan for more
teachers higher pay and better schools
teachers love it parents love it who
wouldn't want better schools in fact an
up-and-coming politician named Edward
loves it so much he makes Jim's plan the
centerpiece of his platform once Edward
signs on Jim decides suspending even
more of the union's money on
contributions to Edwards campaign and
with all that extra money
Edward is able to outspend his opponents
the plan works perfectly
Edward gets elected the government
spends more money on the public school
system the Union gets more dues from all
the new spending and Edward gets more
Union contributions for his next
campaign it's a well-oiled machine
except there's one piece missing where
did all of that money come from in the
first place
we know that Edward got his money from
the Union the Union got its money from
Sally and Sally got her money from the
government but where did the government
get all of its money from from all of us
of course first we work hard to make the
money and some of that money is
automatically deducted from our
paychecks to pay for government
employees like Sally then some of that
money is automatically deducted from her
paycheck to pay dues to unions like
Jim's
Jim uses some of that money to make
campaign
patience of politicians like Edward and
Edward uses those contributions to
campaign for more teachers like Sally
and a machine just keeps growing and
growing non-stop because of us our money
is the fuel for decades
teachers units have been among our
nation's largest political donors they
influence who gets elected and who
doesn't
perhaps because of this the United
States now spends more money per student
on public schools than at any time in
our history we're getting the more money
part of Jim's plan but without the
better schools part and that's because
the machine isn't designed to produce
better schools it's designed to produce
more money for unions and more donations
for politicians it's a political
perpetual motion machine and the only
way to stop it is to break the chain of
automatic money transfers from taxpayers
to the government to the unions and then
back to politicians it's our money that
fuels it so it's up to us to do
something about it before the fuel
finally runs out
[Music]
you
you